I first won on tinder - oh man this is
gonna be more difficult than I thought
to find someone extra to spend time with
outside of my marriage
[Music]
my wife and I have considered ourselves
polyamorous for quite a while she's
always been open to meeting other
wonderful ladies having a short little
flings I wasn't looking for a deep
connection I was definitely looking for
fun and a little spice I guess you could
say
I saw this redhead and all of my bells
started my house at my head just the
fact that she had red hair and had an
Australian accent is my pretty much my
checklist so I get very excited my eye
socket on there I moved from Australia
to North America four years ago I grew
up in a very happy Jewish household with
strong religious values but I hadn't
been in a relationship in the
traditional sense for a long time I
thought holy [__] what do I say and I
immediately went into the whole idea
that I have a wife and I'm just looking
to have a fun time I didn't get to no
key and I immediately went oh okay bye
that's a shame sorry best of luck but we
ended up having this really interesting
intelligent engaging conversation I
found him fascinating and charming and
lovely and great so I agreed to a date
we met up at a bar and I was terrified
actually having the knowledge that a
beautiful red-haired girl of my dreams
would be interested in me and did match
with me was very intimidating we
immediately clicked hard we had a great
conversation a great rapport everything
in common same sense of humor I could
tell that something was going to happen
[Music]
at the end of our first day and I was on
my train ride home to my wife I could
not wait to have them meet each other I
was a little worried that things had not
gone as well on her end as they had on
my end considering that I'm married and
she's not and she may not want to weigh
herself down with that kind of [__]
but uh
we kept talking and she quickly put my
fears to rest I wanted to go out again
after our second date we went back to
Kate's all of the things that happen at
people's places happened at Kate's very
quickly I felt myself falling for her
much to my surprise and my wife's
approach and then I started looking
forward to getting her and my wife
together
[Music]
so I set up my wife on a date with my
tinder girlfriend and that was an
interesting feeling meeting the wife I
was I was probably more nervous heading
into that and then meeting him I'd seen
photos I knew she was really hot and I
had already slept with her husband so I
didn't know how the night would go and
then after a few glasses of wine I said
all right then we drunk enough to talk
about this yet can we address the pink
elephant in the room
we had a quick talk about that and they
were very clearly obviously open and
honest about everything
and that date ended well
[Music]
it started off as just a sex fun
drinking threesomes Pat nights
and then there was a shift from it being
just a bit of casual fun and he just
kind of been I found a little addition
into the marriage bed Dave and I
realized we had very strong feelings for
each other and we're maybe fully in love
and then it became a relationship and we
had to figure out what that meant and
how to tell people I'm stupid lucky and
crazy happy and it's surprisingly easy
to manage having two wonderful women in
my life that are smoking hot and want to
sleep with me
the wife and I get along very very well
I visit them I I stay there all three of
us have been away on vacation together
their relationship is still honest and
open and strong stronger
oh my god we're gonna have a one-year
anniversary and my wife's gonna be at
the dinner that's crazy
you
[Music]
grande is very much about instant
validation so it's very this is what I
want when can we do it let's do it now
[Music]
my last relationship lasted six years
and we actually met on an app called
scruff so there are people out there who
have very successful relationships from
these kind of dating apps however
there's sort of needles in a gay stack
he messaged me and said look I think
you're really cute let's go out on a
date and go and have dinner and then
obviously he'd sent me all of the [__]
shots all of the are shots all of the
naked body shots my first thought was oh
Grindr this is where this is going
[Music]
we had this beautiful dinner at this
beautiful restaurant overlooking Sydney
Harbour and it was all amazing and we
went for a walk along circular Cay I was
attracted to him he was attracted to me
and then we got back to his house and
the events unfolded I very distinctly
remember watching RuPaul's Drag Race
sounds so cliche and so gay but you know
who doesn't love RuPaul he puts his hand
on my leg and and he sort of looks
really intensely into my eyes and it was
at that stage where we were just about
to kiss
we looked at each other and you thought
it's go time
then he said so I have this thing when
someone says so here's this thing you
sphincter kind of clenches a little bit
and you think what have I gotten myself
into
I thought he's gonna tell me that he has
like eight nipples like and he's
lactating or he's gonna tell me that he
has like two penises
I was about to sort of pull the phone
out and text message my best friend for
the emergency call
oh look grandmas in hospital so you need
to come right now he says to me I'd like
you to blow for me my natural instinct
was I'm good to go my jaws
double-jointed like let's do this he
then turns to me and says look I really
would get off if you blew for me and I
thought wait do you want me to come join
me to give you a [__] what would you
like me to do and he pulls out this bag
to be honest I was a little afraid and I
thought to myself this is something that
I haven't come across before he looked
at me like a puma that was about to eat
a meerkat and he said so I have this
fetish where I like to watch you blow up
balloons I was like why and he said it's
just my thing I just that's what I do
maybe I set a point in my life where I
thought to myself I'm so starved for
attention maybe I just give it a go
anyway so he hands me this packet of
balloons and pulls one out and I
proceeded to blow one up I was blowing
this balloon up and blowing it up and I
got to a stage where you know how you
sort of hide behind a corner and then
you poke your head out then you're like
surprised I was like so what do I do now
he said blow it up so it pops in your
face
his voice sort of changed a little bit
now is almost a little bit Exorcist lots
of balloons in your face popped up
balloons in your face portable words in
your face I was like ah okay so pop the
balloon in my face it hit me in the nose
and it was kind of a little bit painful
and I thought where is my future headed
the final balloon that he gave me he was
very specific he dug through that bag of
balloons and he found that pink one
you know those novelty balloons like
clowns have them and it was very phallic
and he was just like little like I
wasn't even turned on in the slightest
like there was nothing about scenario
that made me think to myself this is hot
there was nothing hot about it he
started playing with these nipples he
was staring at me with these like crazy
eyes like he was masturbating furiously
and I blew up the balloon to the point
where I thought in my head that it was
gonna pop and I pulled it to the side
and I looked at him and he said two
words
[Music]
he made noises that I'd never quite
heard before except from watching blue
whale documentaries then it was done
then I was sitting there and I was like
wow okay so my turn I came here for sex
like what what what what's going on he
said to me no no I'm done now look I've
got a really early morning tomorrow so I
think it's best we ended here so I
walked out of there with the biggest
blue balls I've ever had in my life
I've heard stories that a lot of people
in the gay community know him and he had
blanket messages everybody in the hopes
that somebody would respond it felt very
selfish and I left there at the end
going [__] I should get on Grindr cuz I
really need to get laid
[Music]
you